- [Interviewer] This seems like
this might be the lowest
point in your life right now.
You seem a little worse off
than the last time I interviewed you.
- I'd say it's really low.
I'd say I'm ready for Russian roulette,
would put a bullet in my head,
and let me out of this motherfucker.
- [Interviewer] Alright, Timothy,
Timothy where are you
from, where'd you grow up?
- Born and raised in Chicago, Illinois.
My dad was Chicago policeman
who drank alcohol heavily
and would beat your ass
if you breathe too much.
He was gone on the alcohol.
- [Interviewer] Alright hold
on, I interviewed you before.
I don't recognize you.
- Okay well, what do you want me to do?
- [Interviewer] No, it's okay,
it's all good, it's all good.
How you been?
- I'm alright.
I'm living on the
streets, I don't like it.
I served three years in the Navy
with an honorable discharge.
I'm sick of this shit.
I deserve a break somewhere.
I wanna get my HUD-VASH
and get a room somewhere.
- [Interviewer] Where'd
you sleep last night?
- I don't sleep, I walk around.
- [Interviewer] What
keeps you up at night?
- I don't take dope, I drink alcohol.
That's one of my pitfalls.
- [Interviewer] Alcohol is your downfall?
- Oh yeah, when I lived in
Arizona until skin cancer got me
I lived with the daughter of the devil,
Cynthia, crystal meth smoking bitch
who was more crazy than goddamn,
she was just crazy.
And her daughter,
they were both smoking that crystal shit
and I got lucky.
I got $12 an hour job at the
sub shop on South 24 Street
so I had money coming in
to wherever I was living.
I was living with Carol,
she worked at Maharani.
It was on Thomas and 38 Street.
And she would close the
door and she told me,
"When you come back just
turn the knob, walk in.
Turn on the swamp cooler,
you get it cool in here."
And then I'd drink my 12 pack of Heiniken.
- [Interviewer] Alcohol's
been your thing for how long?
- Since I was 11 years old.
I'm just telling you the truth.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- My mom and dad would
pour a beer into a glass
and I was just a child
and I'd call it 'fuzz'.
I'd say, "Can I have the fuzz?"
And my dad would go,
"You can drink the fuzz.
Here's the fuzz."
And that got me into
alcohol at 11 years old.
It wasn't good.
- [Interviewer] You've
been drinking ever since?
- I've been drinking ever since.
I've been drinking
heavily and it's alright.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- 65.
- [Interviewer] 65.
Do you have kids?
- I have no kids.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
- I've had hundreds of
girlfriends ready to marry,
to live with, except
that weird bitch Cynthia,
crystal meth smoker.
The chick was nuts.
She was scary nuts and
when I was 31 years old
I'd seen nuts in the Navy
but she was really nuts.
And I got skin cancer and
I got out of that town
and made it to California, finally.
First San Diego, lived on
the streets, Market Street,
you might have heard of it in San Diego
where you have nothing,
you don't gotta break common from nobody.
- [Interviewer] And what was
your childhood like again?
I know you told me before.
Your childhood?
- It was alright.
My dad was Chicago policeman.
He was honest and upright
but he was a heavy, heavy,
heavy, heavy alcoholic,
scary at the time.
And he just had a habit
of beating people up
because he had big arms and big hands.
- [Interviewer] What about you?
- Oh he beat my ass hundreds of times,
if not thousands of times.
And for nothing,
until I started thinking
he's probably nuts.
He must be nuts.
My own dad is nuts.
He was a good father, he
supported us but no, he was nuts.
- [Interviewer] And what about your mom?
- They're both dead now.
My mom put up with his alcoholism.
Why, I don't know.
She was an honest Christian like myself.
And I didn't ask her about it.
Me and my mom had a habit of
sitting in our living room
which was in the basement
of Chicago, our home,
16 26 North Newcastle,
and we would watch Benny
Hill and news or whatever,
and my mom might have two
bottles of beer maybe.
She didn't have it every
night because finances.
My dad was Chicago police
and she worked at Sears,
Sears in Roebuck and it was alright.
- [Interviewer] This seems like
this might be the lowest
point in your life right now.
You seem a little worse off
than the last time I interviewed you.
- [Timothy] I'd say it's really low.
I'd say I'm ready for Russian roulette,
would put a bullet in my head,
let me out of this motherfucker
because I don't get a break.
I did three years in the Navy
and I don't get a break anywhere.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- [Timothy] Friends that
aren't living anymore.
No, they're all dead.
They thought smoking crystal
meth and shooting Mexican mud
directly in their vein was a way to live.
You know what they got out of it?
Overdose and dead.
I don't know where they're at now,
they're probably in the morgue somewhere.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- [Timothy] Lesson.
To get in the fox hole in Vietnam and duck
because the gooks are gonna be
trying to shoot your head off
which they did for three years.
That was the Navy.
- [Interviewer] How did
Vietnam change your life?
- Vietnam.
When I got back to Miami Beach, Florida,
I was brought by K6 Navy
SEAL team outta 'nam
and we went to Miami Beach.
And they gave me $4,000 cash
and the man said to me,
"Look, I'm a fucking dope fiend.
Where's the dope at around here?"
I said,
"I'm new in the town,"
He goes,
"This is Miami Beach.
Here, here's your money."
Boom!
And I lived in a motel
somewhere in Miami Beach.
Where, I don't know, it began with an 'S'.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- When I was in high school
and my friend, Mike Roach, brother
just got back from Vietnam, John,
and he was strung out on heroine.
He'd get out of the bed and do this.
He'd stare at the floor.
He wouldn't talk, he'd
just stare at the floor.
And his brother Pat lived
down Austin Boulevard,
he heard about it so he came and got him
and he moved him into
his two bedroom flat.
He had a two bedroom home down here,
another one upstairs apartment building
and that's about it.
- [Interviewer] What's
your biggest regret?
- I don't know.
I have no idea.
- [Interviewer] Okay, you don't have to.
- I've had some but I can't
remember any right now.
- [Interviewer] It's alright.
- Because they got it true, I'm buzzing
because I drank a couple
of Olde English 800s
but I need some more
because I'm a drinker.
- [Interviewer] Alright
Timothy, great seeing you again.
I'm gonna set you off for the afternoon.
- Yeah and you're gonna
give me some cash right?
- [Interviewer] That's
what I'm talking about.
That's how this works.
Well I wish you the
best of luck out there.
I hope things turn-
- Yeah I'm on the street.
I got no shoes, they stole my shoe.
I had nice Adidas shoes, Adidas gym shoes.
- [Interviewer] Who stole your shoes?
- I don't know.
Some black guy said,
"Hey man, what are you doing?"
And he mumbled something else
and I laid down and stole my shoe.
You see it's a weird world on the streets.
You ain't got nothing
coming and most everyone,
they got serious mentally
retarded problems.
It's more than problems, they're nuts.
And they don't even know
it, they'll try to kill you.
- [Interviewer] That's crazy.
- Alright, well I'm ready to go.
- [Interviewer] Alright
Timothy, thank you very much.
- You got the money, right?
- [Interviewer] Of course I do.
(laughing)
And I'll get you some shoes too.
- [Timothy] Oh I've been
through this shit, man.
I had a nice job at fucking
Action Office Furniture.
I do thank you, I do thank you sir.
- [Interviewer] I'll
get you some lunch too.
- [Crew Member] Alright we are all set.
- [Timothy] Because I'm
living on these streets.